dans the huntsman dont j'ai quitté on
peut dire que c'est passé par trois
villes donc ce qui était le crains c'est
que j'étais en pole aux deux maintenant
je suis en france je change très vite
très vite voilà vingt secondes et tu dis
si tu vas vers la gare et tu prends la
place libre il tue par voilà comme ça
[Musique]
oui
le premier jour de garde nous sommes
nous étions dans une très grande panique
c'est pour cela que nous avons de ce que
nous avons décidé de fuir le pays je
n'aime pas que ma fille va entendre tous
les bruits de bombardements ça va ça va
lui donner un grand trauma et que ce que
ça va ça va resté avec elle tous avides
[Musique]
nous sommes venus ici pour demander un
hébergement
et pour
penser comment il faut faire pour
légaliser notre ce jour dans le pays
pour faire les démarches pour les
documents documents et les papiers et
tous
[Musique]
la situation est surréaliste ans et la
guerre dans mon pays est ce assez
mais je sais pas comment l'expliquer
parce que ce sont des sentiments
vraiment très dur parce que je ne dors
pas je ne mange pas je suis deux jours
au téléphone ne réalise pas ce qui se
passe
j'espère de commencer ma vie de nouveau
donc je parle français donc je peux
trouver un boulot j'ai des amis ici
[Musique]
la cassette you d'honneur
qui est spécifique ici pour les
ukrainiens c'est qu'ils auront droit à
un statut qui a été particulièrement
adopter pour eux qui s'appelle la
protection temporaire ce qui veut dire
ils ont une protection immédiate ils ont
pas besoin d'entrer dans un parcours de
demandes d'asile d'attendre la réponse
est ensuite d'avoir un titre de séjour
mais le titre de séjour qu'ils
obtiennent leur permet normalement de
travailler
[Musique]
et
c'est d'origine ukrainienne et moi je
vois ce qui se passe là bas et je vais
je vais peur que mon cerveau explose
tellement c'est dur être là il ne
pouvoir rien faire tout mon coeur je
souhaite de tout mon coeur de tout le
monde mon esprit et d'auto je suis là
bas et quand je suis venu ici je savais
qu'ils les gens qui vient se stresser
une autre culture et tout est différent
il les routes difficiles les le stress
qu'ils ont vécu les les nuits et les
journées ce lycée rien dans les bois
sous les bombes au moins je peux
discuter avec les gens pour les rassurer
[Musique]
je commence la matinée en disant est ce
que vous êtes toujours en vie j'ai très
très peur franchement maintenant je vous
parle ça me fait mal bon alors je
préfère ne plus parler parce que je vais
pleurer
ce jour d'accord dès ce soir et tous les
jours qui viennent autant plus
nécessaire au tessin d'accord non sur un
niveau bas ce budget nationaux au motel
à
[Musique]
l'état
mais je suis bénévole j'arrive tout de
suite ici des légendes juste pour
traduire parce que je parle russe
ukrainienne anglais français je reste
dehors pour demande s'il baissera
hébergement ils sont dix voix le juste
le papier il me demande lequel papier
qu'est ce qu'il peut avoir en france
lequel lequel de quelles aides il
pouvait y avoir et compliqué je fatigue
et beaucoup mais je ne sais pas s'aimer
des forces quand les gens n'aillent
heureuse que je peux aider je ne sais
pas si je crois tout toute ma vie je
voulais aider les gens
[Musique]